How'd you do? If you got 14 ounces, great work. Let's see how we got that
answer. When we do ratio problems, it's important to put the ratio in words
before we put numbers. So, the ratio I need to write is the amount of chocolate
chips over the number of cookies. So, the ratio we want to write here is how
many ounces of chocolate chips we need for how many cookies. We know that
there's 8 ounces of chocolate chips, so we know the amount of chocolate chips.
But we don't know the number of cookies because this tells us we have 2 dozen
cookies. For those of you that don't know, one dozen is equal to 12. For
example, when you buy a dozen eggs, you get 12 eggs. So, if we have 2 dozen
cookies, that's going to be 24 cookies. So we need 8 ounces of chocolate chips
for 24 cookies. The question says, how many ounces of chips we need to make 42
cookies? So, the number of cookies is 42, and we want to know how many ounces of
chocolate chips we need. We know the number of cookies we need to make is 42,
and we have to find out how many ounces of chocolate chips. So, this is what
we're looking for. I'm going to use the variable c in this case. We have two
ratios. When we set them equal to each other, that creates a proportion. To
solve a proportion, we simply cross-multiply. When we cross-multiply, we get 24
times c is equal to 8 times 42. So, we get 24 c equals 8 times 42 is 336. To
solve this, all we have to do is divide both sides by 24. 336 divided by 24 is
14. So, we get c equals 14, which means we need 14 answers of chocolate chips to
make 42 cookies. Are you ready to try another one?